okay guys it's your boy psychobabble and
it looks like we're back at this help me
just this microphone you know I don't
like that it's like - like not adjusted
okay
um it's my skin be working like the eyes
of dogs I had a boss with the sale
I'm day a now I can I know and I'm just
a dog typing okay I guess I'll check
another sent more dogs
I think he's not a dog but this place
really put dogs to work you know once
I've fallen down a mighty relative Lex
laughter is my hair
yeah that's you loud means I don't think
I want to lower this thing a little bit
[Music]
okay what the heck
okay great sorry the volume was just a
little too loud
and I gotta let this die again and now
my distractions out I promise I promise
okay let's check I guess this is where
the boss laughs is the boss that little
thing my airline again everyone happen
again like mr. docks I like if this
happens one more time like I'll have to
fill our port to the Great Hall
now please no sir but I understand you
know by the way you are already called
from the Great Hall Jesus what I don't
know the date has been it but as a lot
abiding citizen and biere nothing don't
worry I'm out you know all right all
right sir
okay and I get back don't work yeah yeah
hey so Thank You mr. dog yeah okay I
guess I gotta get back to my chemical
I've got crazy over there can I go over
there now
I don't know my later where's my cab my
god I feel kind of where it'd be the
only person that's like not a dog I know
it sounds a little racist but like it's
true you know like I'm that dog I think
it might give a guy yes
eyes are pretty dry I remember
everything you know everything okay am i
just literally going and getting all the
piano is okay yep okay so we're gonna
start okay so I'll start with all the
ones on the right okay I got 100 what is
that in the ground what is that chicken
trash on the ground
that's dark oh my god that scared of me
actually well this is like a cage why is
it a little freaking flash I keep
turning off it's so annoying every time
we exit a room the flashlight there I'd
love lots of a Jewess gang anything over
here nap just another waste of my time
it's fine
my time is over I am a you know I had
time I was in valium all suits got what
a three more piano I guess how could
they how could they know how could they
knew all of this how could they know all
this I think it was reading no no that
monster seemed oddly familiar that it's
almost we've seen them before
fascinating I guess kind of day I think
it'd be more fascinated they like spell
that correctly or maybe half the allure
is that they didn't spell yeah you know
I don't know you know the Medicaid
developer it would be some grand scheme
of things noise I think it's Daniel up
there anymore jumping over here
am I like a hunter is I mean why is it
called fire why does anyone know what is
that scrod let us howling I'm not gonna
dog out there another piano King okay
that's fine piano to get an instrument I
guess okay all right so now it's good
all the rooms the left
um the elevator
so it's Crotty er I mean he never study
you know you seen one I see you tomorrow
you know like you seen them all some
okay okay I'm the son away I wanna budge
yeah no okay that's hit a lot of sex any
panic Ethan here I step out of the dirt
once it was all like the old days I was
in the office and okay
fascinating so financial document oh my
god
that's a scariest thing of them all okay
yeah that's it the Scott thing can you
tell that's like a spine or just like
Lucis what I better get to work
but that's guy got here is that gonna
work and we just check make sure this is
when I looked at my apartment by myself
that's the exit let me see what's
another room real quick
hello Meister dare I'm not kind of weird
what am i holding something the kitchen
okay another waste of my time how walks
like that certainly not me here wouldn't
want there's a random zooming out it's
okay I got like a microphone like when
the webcams and like follows the face
but whenever my face is B it's a
homeless people it's behind the
microphone it gets all confused
like a what is this okay yeah yeah I'm
trying to sell anything going somewhere
that's on their business well I saw
tents
tied up and pushed around like a dog
that me choose your words carefully
[ __ ] come now no need to be hostile baby
I'm just here to give you a present
what are you talking about Master it's
just a lot of thing it failed what help
okay I knew you'd make that right choice
yeah that one that time I was right
I think Epping was that chalk
whysa piano key like glowing I don't
know what they gave me like cat food or
something who is that
I don't weigh anywhere beyond oh he's in
here no beyond out guys just another
waste of my time chest I know that way
it's the one time you know what's a
really good point click Graham Bell and
King
I'm still missing a few keys what is
this one - what one Lightning three to
put their own water guess there's one
more all right I am I say Simon kershel
now uh one two three four okay so I must
be missing one right it's not crazy
this is so annoying I missed the one now
I gotta pay the piper
you know guess you're gonna throw these
again trash trash just a bunch of trash
my guys so Harry let's see here any
trash for me you know Nance I'm here to
click your trash
I'm here's your coat your trash
okay it's at this time same powers at
this time okay so that nonsense
financial documents yeah we've been
there's aa before this is sad lying but
let's check the elevator
I only haven't actually checked the L
over yet not working anything here nap
that my ma'am just a chalk man you know
can't check this one won't podge it's
annoying
this is where the person's scared the
bejesus out of me
what is that is that they key right
there no I miss the merits it place lots
of H wine and history bucks she this
trash can not then I don't that this is
a weird like not pointing like it's
citrus like you go over is a this is
like a PR story type of game that Chuck
okay there we go I got the missing ban
okay that's annoying it was like hitting
next to it so like the expiration point
didn't even chain you better walk by it
mmm okay let me see how fast that camera
go that fast like like so skinny I think
the keys all with their air and okay
come on lil fast I sent ya little faster
wreck out in there or again there I'm
getting there in a slow and steady wins
the race you know I think it's just one
109
one two three four
oh my god yeah I saw my unformed
substance my god any a book work in your
book were written every one of them the
days that were formed for me when I was
yet there was another familiar I guess
I'm not very religious sir and what did
you mean by that are you trying to tell
me something he told me I'm dead I am
NOT saying anything yet and then are
they now bang I'm mister wrapping your
hair because you're one of them what the
April doers what you've come a long way
but still isn't enough he did not face
the true monster yet but you get in
class head may be the one can find both
joy and suffering and his memories want
you pass through the star there will be
no turning back payback
I like there is no doubt my blonde good
luck but I don't know what's on there
but screw
okay what is this what I act
act just what I fed nothing that liked
us like my hands Dec well well well wow
wow wow
okay well say it was a
thank you in the rear just got here
hello lady and Mayas headlight the
doctor is waiting for you baby I'm the
third where I'm death all right in case
he gets not this one no that's the first
room to the right I don't care I thought
this one that's the second one and they
were to the right okay I guess this one
was a BAM hello sir I thought I could
get my prize okay but about what the
rabbi my Bama is a rabbit how that I got
here
see my last smoke it's bad for the baby
life was good now regrets just a few
maybe alright let me just go back
straight to that room ours is that this
is the first one second one there don't
you ever to this okay no okay and
Madigan's left leg is nothing like I
remember this
tell
9:00 in town okay you know I really get
that can I eat something okay I check
that those two rooms
do this one all right great one of these
gimmicks again I don't that doesn't make
jump-scare in here for sure
I guess not
that's right take down through here
seven okay seven to nine
thousand here punter lock jars
it's like the hell
all right
now
[Music]
okay this is the mannequins
but let me just check to see if there's
another torso right here three some in
there well I got the K and the second go
to that locked door anyway here real
quick the heck
and I can't I got a bunch of likes maybe
this open
I'm gonna freakin jump scared I'm gonna
hide you I'm scared that's for sure
wait can I still go this way no okay
it's not gonna like this what I'm
talking about this one let's go to the
next one
I think it's right here now this is it
oh my god
what's this jail there's just so sad huh
it's her knees like animals what the
hell's going on here
Hey what the hell are you doing all
right should I like rate visit all these
places I was a really cool light thing
mmm tickle Eric picked up at the house
this thing hello sorry and I need to
bother ya but just passed out through
her hair
yes okay good
I'm sorry no I think that's disgusting
I've done it yeah yeah I'm Barry I
really don't remember actually I don't
know what's going on here
president is waiting for you in his room
thanks bro and really walk in here Jesus
yeah mr. president there is that him
away with no shirt on yeah mr. president
yes sir hey Barry
oh yeah yeah when was the last time you
were here 10 years ago mapping a lot of
things have changed Pammy
Sanjay move to the desk how's life
treatin ya pepping I heard about the
baby actually I have other matters in my
mind and I can't watch any Amanda bang
never mind you I asked that questions
here yeah we're the first person that I
trusted when we started building what we
have right now so I will go easy on you
Tomic how's your wife always a trainer
and that may make Claire know let me
break Claire and I what is happening
outside your reign is over
yeah probably think you can run away but
do you forget one thing that trusting me
was that biggest mistake in your life
laughs yeah yeah well I think yeah I can
get out of here alive I've been dead
since you took my wife I'm not gonna
make the same mistake again bang
it's maybe this time I guess now now now
that now
now
not get my hair wet just straighten that
- you know just driving me nuts
I'm dead [ __ ] they write all this how
I'm so sorry
okay I really didn't understand that
game at all